so pablo matches the amount of pitches
he threw his last outing this will be
officially his 18th start of the year
and he picks up his first strikeout here
strikes out mookie betts
one away tony gone selena pitches in his
sixth game here tonight
his last timeout one run over three
innings in relief
another 3-2 on the way and a good eye
for garrett cooper gonzalon thought he
had it
he pokes another one to right this one
playable for mookie bets and ultimately
godzilla has to throw just three
additional pitches
2-2 to godzlin a swing and a miss he's
down on strikes that's
five k's for pablo his fourth of the
night on a change up
the turner is in near to right field
going back out of cooper still back onto
the track
he makes the over the shoulder catch two
steps shy of the wall
got him swinging brought a lot of the
plate but he's swinging a mist from
panic
pablo lopez this one's gonna get to the
wall
pablo's on his way to second he's got
himself
a one-out double
and punching one to first muncie on a
hot shot has it on one bound stand the
inning
and the line drive the right that'll top
spin down and get by garrett cooper
billings are after a 12th pitch at bat
is on his way to third
and the dodgers are in business here in
the fourth
and now will smith in this scoreless
game will try to pick up
bellinger that is a basement to left
field and the dodgers have the game's
first run
bellinger and smith back-to-back hits to
open the fourth
[Music]
swanson base it the other way and
extends the hitting streak to seven
games
three consecutive singles to open the
fourth after they went the first three
innings without a hit
lopez in trouble here in the fourth 3-2
pitch coming
swinging a miss that is strike three on
a 2-2 from lopez
bouncing ball left side won't be an easy
play lopez with a bare hand throws low
pablo gets the strike out of bentz and
leaves the bases loaded
a chase and a strikeout two gone in the
fourth
the 1-1 pitch is shot back at the middle
and behind the back at second
through into center hit for rojas
fly ball center field but no big deal
for cody bellinger
a two-out single but no damage done four
shutout innings for tony godzilla and
the one-nothing
now the marlins hand it over to stephen
oaker this will be his third game
sharply hit diving play by jazz up with
it throw it up
first in time jazz chisholm jr
with a beautiful play now we talk about
this
all the time jazz is going to be a
special player
special players make special plays and
that was one
now one for the highlight reel this year
wow to the backhand
on the dive got rid of it quick
here's the 1-0 a pop fly
into center field for bellinger
one away in the six dodgers one marlins
nothing tony gonzalon very good tonight
he's needed to be every bit that good
with the dodgers getting him just one
run of support
his best outing of the season and jake
reed comes on for his major league debut
jake reed 28 years old born in tucson
arizona
went to helix charter high school in the
mesa california now makes his major
league debut
up the middle diving sliding play and
the throw is off the mark
marta the tying run at second as the
payoff comes home and he strikes him out
first career strikeout for reed getting
cooper for the second out of the six
with two outs it's jesus aguilar who was
oh for two
the o2 pitch ocular hits one sharply to
the shortstop and he gets five
gavin lucks into left center field
coming around third martay he's gonna
score
and we're back where we began all tied
up it's 1-1 in the six
now to right field it'll drop for a base
hit
aguila on his way to third maggie to
second base
and it uh doesn't look like they're
going to pitch to sanchez but
rather load the bases the 2-2 pitch from
reed
that is caught at second by chris taylor
and the inning is over 12 pitches ended
in a single
there's a called strike three and mookie
betts is down looking
the 3-1 ball four second walk by muncie
yanks the line drive base hit in the
left up to second goes muncie
solo homer gave the dodgers the lead
they'd eventually win by that score but
he comes up empty here as
floro strikes him out
[Applause]
oh and two slowly rolled to
turner at third up with it quick but
jazz is
too fast phil bickford comes on in a tie
game in the
seventh after the two out base hit from
chisholm he's on the face starling
martin
a 1-0 pitch he takes off throw down
right there and the ending is over
taylor putting the tag down and a good
throw from will smith
chisholm wants him to take a look but
call on the field is
out they're gonna challenge that angle
he might have gotten in there
but we have our answer wow
how is that even possible i can't
believe that that is
unbelievable to me
sharply hit into left base it for taylor
base runner in this tie game
there goes taylor here's the throw from
alfaro it goes into center field
taylor hesitated and will hold so pujols
has done a really good job against
lefties
they're going to walk him
high chopper left side panic has to wait
for it to come down off balance throw
and he gets the out at first
[Applause]
and that gets martay now it's a breaking
ball
86 miles an hour flying out of the hand
of nelson
martin goes throw down to second
and martay in there safely nelson fires
3-1
bouncing ball to first backhand pujols
he feeds nelson to the bag and ends the
inning
reaches out pokes this one into right
it's a lead-off hit for betts
another two and two chopped two first
aguilar goes to second for one back to
first it's a double play
the one two lifted to right center field
cooper drifting back turning around it's
off the wall
and turner holds out with a single
miss with the fastball here and the go
ahead run does move into scoring
position
the pitch out to right field
garrett cooper's there and the marlins
get to the bottom of the ninth hitting
and here it comes
and he goes the other way against the
ship
and there's your potential winning run
that's outside ball four good at bat is
right
first and second nobody out one and two
on panic who bunted a couple foul
and now strikes out swinging one and two
from alexander
slow roller turner can't come up with it
will have the bases loaded base is
loaded in a 1-1 game in the ninth the
3-2 pitch
he struck him out blake trina in his
35th game this year
bouncing ball to third turner's got it
across the diamond
kept his foot on the bag and we go to
extra innings
with will smith as the placed runner at
second base and chris taylor drops down
the bunt alfaro fields throws to third
applies the tag
got him what an athletic play by jorge
alfaro
my goodness he's quick out from behind
home plate
overheads and bertie gets the tag down
that was out number one albert pools
ground ball
[Music]
[Applause]
well with two outs you've got martay
running on contact from second to base
hit to the athleta to end the ball game
gets away from
smith throw down to third and it gets
[Music]
[Applause]
away
[Applause]
it kicked off the glove barely got out
of the grass but a low
maybe rushed throw that then got away
from turner
and lux had to rush it marty
in safely